é bom pessoal é uma satisfação enorme tá
aqui com vocês hoje é muito emocionante
também né até porque a última vez que eu
estive aqui foi a mais ou menos três
anos atrás durante a minha formatura aí
eu fui a primeira turma que se formou
neste ato então É de fato muito
emocionante poder voltar e vou poder
contar um pouquinho para vocês o que eu
vi no mercado do que aprendi até aqui e
de alguma forma poder contribuir para o
processo de construção coletiva né de
construção de conhecimento coletivo aí é
o Curioso é que o que eu tenho para
falar para vocês hoje é muito menos
exato do que vocês possam esperar de um
engenheiro
é isso porque eu acabei mudando um
pouquinho rumo da minha carreira ainda
na época do estágio fiz um estágio em
pesquisa e desenvolvimento na área de
Telecom e eu acabei percebendo que por
mais que se tenha um bom sorte os raros
processos sistemas tecnologias o ponto
chave para se atingir resultado está
sempre nas pessoas são as pessoas a
solução a causa das soluções a causa dos
problemas e também das soluções as
pessoas que são responsáveis pelos
processos de transformação que nos levam
aos resultados então que eu vou falar
aqui um pouquinho hoje é um vínculo é a
gente analisar um pouquinho desse poder
de transformação das pessoas junto com
outro tema super pertinente super
relevante o nosso dia a dia que é
sustentabilidade
a sustentabilidade até então foi um tema
muito discutido e muitas vezes é por uma
simples uma simples questão de marketing
de propaganda O que é bonito Se a
sustentável É bonito ser verde e em vez
de talvez não seja a melhor cor para
definir seus também sustentabilidade
talvez ostentabilidade de devesse
acompanhar uma cor vermelha porque é uma
cor de alerta ou qualquer outra cor que
significa a gente precisa agir tem um
sinal eminente de alerta de atenção
sustentabilidade precisa ser tratado
talvez como a nossa tentabilidade de
atender um pedido de SOS do planeta
talvez por isso ao pudesse ser vermelho
e até então né as empresas que trataram
sustentabilidade sempre como estratégia
de marketing as empresas vêm repensando
um pouco isso não é isso
sustentabilidade passa agora você então
uma estratégia na verdade sobrevivência
E se a gente não tratar assim Pode ser
que daqui a pouco a gente não esteja
aqui para contar um pouco da sua
história também a ficha ainda não caiu
para muita gente que ser sustentável tá
cada um tá em cada um de nossa é uma
responsabilidade de cada um de nós e não
só das empresas existe um paradigma né
que sustentabilidade a coisa do governo
das empresas das ONGs da ONU
eu sei que cada um de nós estamos de
fato comprometidos com essa causa
Oi e a melhor definição de
sustentabilidade que encontrei vem de um
Fórum da ONU que foi o primeiro fórum
que que esse termo começou a ser
divulgada pelo mundo né e é um Fórum de
87 então já faz um tempo né Há 27 anos
atrás eles definiram a sustentabilidade
como o desenvolvimento que satisfaz as
necessidades do presente sem comprometer
a capacidade das Gerações futuras de
satisfazerem as suas próprias
necessidades eu pergunto para vocês se é
27 anos atrás já sentiam Livres buscando
por sustentabilidade por quê que isso
não vingou até hoje
e talvez pelo mesmo motivo pelo qual
vários outros movimentos de mudança não
vingaram as pessoas será que as pessoas
são de fato comprometidas
a ser aquelas pessoas entendem
sustentabilidade como algo maior do que
aquele relatório entregue anualmente que
tem como base três pilares básicos
econômico Social e Ambiental será que
quando as empresas constroem esses
relatórios elas estão preocupados e se
importa com as atitudes das pessoas
e talvez a gente tem que acrescentar um
novo fator aqui e se preocupar um
pouquinho mais o quanto cada um de nós
entrega para esse resultado sustentável
o e atitude é uma coisa que nos
acompanha desde sempre né a sociedade os
pais cobram esse da gente aos Três Anos
de idade por exemplo atitude a saber
fazer xixi né aos 4 anos tomar banho sem
ter que ser lembrado Aos sete gerenciar
sua mesada
o e aos 18 atitude a começar a construir
seu futuro o problema que aos 18 nem
todo mundo sabe o que quer ser quando
crescer nessa época eu me lembro que
meus pais reforçaram muito uma mensagem
para mim que era
o cuidado com essas atitudes do presente
são elas que vão determinar o seu futuro
Oi e aí eu tenho uma história uma
experiência aqui tem muito carinho com
ela por ela e passei a valorizar Ainda
mais quando se ou de uma reconhecida
consultoria me pediu para contar mais
detalhes sobre ela não na final de um
processo seletivo no painel
e ele me falou que é isso me explica
mais sobre a cervejada Oi cervejada tá
bom né vamos contar então bom cervejada
é um evento sempre fez parte da comissão
de formatura de cerveja deram um desses
eventos que tinha para arrecadar fundos
para comissão e só que nesse nesse meio
do caminho nesse projeto eu tinha um
sonho de fazer um intercâmbio também e
conseguiu me preparar mais para o
mercado de trabalho junto com os
esforços meus pais também eu consegui
Fui Morar um tempo na Irlanda chegando
lá eu levei uma bagagem repleta de
sonhos expectativas e anseios e também
te preocupação porque faltava pouco
tempo para o evento acontecer tenho
muita coisa para se fazer ainda
principalmente relacionada Patrocínio
até ser uma coisa muito difícil de se
conseguir né Eu preocupada com isso
preocupado em como que eu podia fazer
para ajudar esse grupo aqui em Santa
Rita de lá longe e aí uma grande mãe
é senta eu me deu um site ele cara vou
pedir patrocínio para escola aqui
Oi e aí eu contei para alguns amigos
eles não mas será será não não sei eu
vou lá ou não eu já tenho o inglês ainda
não mas não já pedir ajuda para um amigo
e a gente foi contar para o diretor lá o
que que era isso apresentei fotos da dos
eventos tudo mais Olha tu não tá
entendendo a gente tá no Polo
Universitário tem um monte de gente
querendo fazer intercâmbio eu nunca vi
ninguém que veio para a Irlanda muito
menos que conheça escola vão aposta
vamos lá e acabou ele topou o patrocínio
ele foi maior patrocinador do evento na
época e foi muito legal E aí ele no
material do do evento tinha um lobo né e
ele falou assim eu sou um homem que tá
ali foi mas você que fez isso foi sendo
engenheira
a pessoa nessas dinheiro mas eu sempre
tive comigo design gráfico como um hobby
algo que me encanta e que me ajuda a
resolver um monte de outros problemas
minha vida e eu também não sou
engenheiro mas eu gosto eu fiz então
assim que fez o site também eu falei sim
aí tô que que você acha do meu site foi
bom seu site é legal tem um monte de
informação legal mas pode ser melhorado
e isso me gerou uma oportunidade de
emprego e aí eu consegui trabalhar nessa
escola por todo o período que eu tava na
Irlanda
E quando voltei e conhecendo um pouco
das histórias né dos intercambistas foi
que eu conheci e consegui compreender
melhor que meus pais queriam dizer sobre
essas atitudes do presente aqui
determinam o seu futuro tem iniciativa
vai corre corre atrás tem atitude e eu
entendi um pouquinho disso é porque no
mundo real essa atitude que parece
simples parece pequena ela é
potencializada principalmente pelo papel
dos líderes não os líderes tem atitude
mãos ele tem o poder de decisão e eles
conseguem mobilizar as pessoas problema
é que quando esses líderes não não
carregam consigo essa essência de ser
sustentável como é que se pode esperar
de uma empresa que ela seja sustentável
Se as pessoas não têm isso em suas
atitudes
bom então mais uma vez o foco é nas
pessoas né e e esses líderes que não
tomando decisões muitas vezes a gente
esquece mas eles são de uma geração em
que sustenta sustentabilidade não era a
premissa básica não tava no plano lá é
tava segundo plantas ser o quarto e
nunca foi a prioridade Então como é que
estão norteando os resultados dessas
empresas
é um ponto principal aqui o que a gente
precisa rever atitude é uma coisa que é
da da atitude sustentável Eleven de
dentro para fora é o que a pessoa
consegue impactar o ambiente é aí vocês
podem perguntar mas é possível
desenvolver isso é possível você vai
dizer para vocês que mudar comportamento
é uma coisa muito difícil muito mesmo
principalmente para adultos é que eu
tenho percebido é que para mudar um
comportamento você precisa estar frente
ou uma necessidade eminente de mudança
você precisa entender você tá cair a
ficha que era preciso mudar talvez fica
mais fácil quando a gente começa a se
deparar com cenários como esses e que o
maior sistema de abastecimento do Estado
de São Paulo Estado mais populoso
e ele opera hoje com menos de 10 por
cento da sua capacidade isso reflete em
374 cidades do Estado de São Paulo
é E essas atitudes essas evidências
estão aí e só não vê quem não quer seja
nas mudanças climáticas sejam nos rios
que estão deixando de existir essa foto
Ela é da semana passada também
Oi e o segundo fator Então tá ligado com
autonomia de um lado o primeiro pela
Então a gente tem atitude sustentável de
cada um de nós segundo fator a autonomia
autonomia é um poder concedido ela vem
de fora para dentro né o ambiente te
proporcionar isso o ambiente de limites
até onde você pode ir Isso tem muito a
ver com a influência que você provoca no
ambiente nas pessoas ponto de atenção
aqui e quando a gente não avalia o poder
de se entregar autonomia de se conceder
o poder para pessoas que não estão
alinhadas à estratégia
Ah eu convido aqui que a gente possa
avaliar quatro quadrantes o primeiro
deles quando vocês tem uma baixa
autonomia e baixo alinhamento
estratégico provavelmente esse cara não
é um líder ou se tá uma posição de
liderança deve ser desenvolvido
rapidamente no segundo se você tem uma
baixa autonomia mas um cara super
alinhado com a estratégia provavelmente
ele tá frustrado e ele não vai ficar
nesse ambiente muito tempo porque ele se
sentia incapaz ele sabe que ele podia
ajudar mais ele não vê espaço para isso
e aqui a gente tem um líder ideal é o
líder que ele tem autonomia e tem
alinhamento estratégico então ele age
como representante da marca um
representante da cultura alguém que
consegue mobilizar de fato as pessoas e
passar um pouco da sua atitude positiva
para os outros
é o principal perigo das organizações
está aqui quando você pede um monte de
autonomia não é muito pensando na
motivação extrínseca na recompensa e
você acaba promovendo as pessoas esquece
de avaliar se elas estão alinhadas à
estratégia aqui a gente tem o líder com
genial lida com genial é aquele que age
em função do próprio desejo Tomas
decisões em função do humor dele e não
se preocupa muito e sustentar aquilo que
se comprometeu atrás na hora de definir
estratégia da organização
o terceiro Pilar é o quanto o ambiente
ou a cultura Empresarial quer ser
sustentável
e pode ser que sim pode ser que não
algumas options né pelo relatório e
mostrar isso inclusive índice de bolsa
de valores e nos rankings o quanto
sustentável nós somos né. Organizações e
o meu convite para vocês é que a gente
possa variar de uma forma mais simples
esses três fatores E como eles funcionam
como equalizadores tá então de um lado a
gente tem atitude sustentável autonomia
EA cultura um cenário e que se tem uma
alta atitude sustentável baixa autonomia
e cultura esse aqui é aquele cara
frustrado é o cara que ele percebe uma
grande grande diferença entre valores e
princípios em frente a organização
e esse segundo cenário o cara tem
atitude tem autonomia EA cultura ainda
não é uma cultura sustentável muito
Possivelmente no médico urto prazo ele
consegue ter bons resultados aqui porque
ele vai mobilizar pessoas em prol de
alguma coisa que ele acredita
é o terceiro cenário é quando você tem
uma pessoa com baixo indicador de
atitude sustentável ele tem uma
autonomia EA cultura é aquela cultura
que tá começando a se mobilizarem seus
sustentável esse cara que invés de
ajudar e vai atrapalhar ele vai colocar
uma ceia de Barreiras porque em cada
decisão tomada Pode ser que ele não siga
estratégia e tem uma tendência de agir
como aquele líder congenial
a branca e a gente possa organizar e
equilibrar um pouco tá bom mais qualquer
um líder ideal então que que você tem
que fazer qualquer combinação de
competências de um líder que consegue
promover a sustentabilidade nas
organizações e fora delas é a minha
proposta por vocês que a gente possa
pensar nessa combinação aqui pulso
a pulso não é no sentido de ser
autoritário muito pelo contrário é no
sentido de ser tão natural que é quase
imperceptível no sentido de ser
constante intermitente toda hora não
para é pulsante
Oi e aí a gente vai entender um
pouquinho o quê que significa isso pulso
significa ter pensamento sistêmico
entendeu um pouco das relações de causa
e efeito e quais são os impactos nas
outras cadeias
O que significa te uniformidade que é
ser coerente Alguém já viu aquele Líder
que defende sustentabilidade piamente no
mundo corporativo e atitude da vida
pessoal não representa aquilo
circunferência pessoal profissional e
vários momentos com pressão Sem pressão
e só ser coerente
a liderança liderança para aquele cara o
líder que é como agente de mudança um
agente de transformação que tem visão de
futuro que consegue imobilizar um grupo
em prol de um resultado em comum e agir
com integridade isso é muito importante
na nossa Cultura
a oeste de senso de coletividade
coletividade algo muito importante
necessário e é muito difícil para a
gente pensar nisso porque eu Total
oposto de ser egoísta ser egoísta aquela
pessoa que tensão nela e não se importa
com os outros em torno mas pelo que a
gente viu de definição do que a cesta
sustentável e tu não tá falando só de se
importar com o outro a gente tá falando
se importar com as futuras gerações
então é total oposto de ser organismo
Isso é muito difícil o ser humano porque
naturalmente egoísta naturalmente a
gente quer fazer os nossos desejos
Oi e o de ousadia
a ser usado significa ter coragem para
desafiar o novo para lidar com coisa
nova para se reinventar se preciso for
porque não é fácil propor um novo é
frente as pessoas que não acreditam e
conseguir mobilizá-los para que aconteça
é para que consiga chegar nesse objetivo
e o problema é que a mudança tem que
começar em cada um de nós se você quer
ser quer ver a mudança no mundo que
começa por você né grande é um grande
exemplo e ele não só disse mas ele
praticou muito disso tem uma história
Super Legal com um exemplo de mudança e
ela pergunta que eu deixo para vocês
hoje é E então vamos nos Reinventar
é obrigado a